that's that's where we're finally
realizing we're so exhausted yeah guys
you you're you're in the best spot ever
you grind it because you loved it yep
now you've decided you love it a little
less now you can travel a little bit
because kobits are like you just want to
live a little bit so how do we get over
that whole like perfectionist control
thing when you realize it's a company
not you guys the saying I'm sorry
to a mistake is more powerful than not
making a mistake
do you know why I'm Never Scared
because when I find that we made a
mistake I call the person I apologize I
make it awesome
you know what can fix your fear
refund people I do it all the time
around the room uh like I mentioned
before we're gonna start with big G
movers over in New Jersey uh and get to
the bottom of what they're looking for
so crazy Big G you're up all right so I
tend to ramble so I'm going to try not
to do that we have been in business for
10 years now we stumbled upon the moving
business basically just out of Need for
for survival
um long story short so started out
needing needing something to do quickly
to get him back on his feet again and it
was him and a friend and a small 15-foot
truck and here we are 10 years later
with a fleet of seven trucks and uh 25
to 30 guys during the busy summer moving
season
and all that to say it is still just him
and I wearing every single hat doing
every single thing stressed out maxed
out taken this as far as we possibly can
how much revenues are doing
Revenue numbers are all you
uh it's it's it's up there it's um you
know the cost of everything has gone
through the roof so profit margins but
about five million and profit
over a million over 20 on a five top
line yeah yeah okay and okay so and that
includes do you take a salary and then
do dividends or no
strictly salary
um for Tracy and um I'm a uh
a helper worker driver driver all that
type of deal
we're in a lot of hats we'll say it
again where does the profit go
back into the business trains to the
business and you know we just uh we've
had a lot of you start off with used
trucks and upgrade we finally got a
brand new truck very first time the
money's gone into the assets that's
where the money sits correct makes sense
correct only money taken out of it is is
a very modest salary for myself
makes sense
um and we're doing we're doing we're
doing well I mean it's his last couple
years have really taken off but it's
we're at that level where it's like uh
we we need uh it is not enough time in
the day you know we have a family of six
a blended family of six kids and it's
just like you know colleges and
everything else going on in sports uh it
just becomes um we are
I hear you talk about making you're
making the cliche mistake of not
three times
yeah we did the hustle only goes so long
and we're I'm feeling it now you know we
we grind it for for many years and we're
at the point where we definitely have to
help you know uh we're we're asking why
did the why did the three times fail
Okay so
for the longest time we we sold
ourselves the story of people are buying
us it's it's Gary and Tracy's story
literally like the cliche American dream
from like below below below nothing
building this out of survival mode to
wow like you guys built a life and and
made it the the comments like when's the
TV show like when are we getting
personal attention me coming out you
know the same an hour later after them
calling doing an estimate and booking it
95 of the time the thing that is always
shocking to people
about my company when they realize I did
the complete reverse even though I was
me
right
right so so we're we're kind of you know
why you know why no
because the reason you're over it is you
don't need it for your self-esteem and
ego anymore
interesting yeah so what what people
don't realize is there's a subconscious
element because it's such a gorgeous
story and it feels good good for you but
I did it by creating awareness about me
but in not being my business mom
you made it your business model on top
of it being your story a hundred percent
yeah and so you just need to unwind that
now and good news you're going to be
you're only scared about do you remember
the boogeyman or like a witch or like
whether it's skiing or or kissing a boy
or girl or swimming or riding a bike
literally the only thing that is [ __ ]
you up right now is fear a hundred
percent a hundred percent and I would
argue that the reason the three people
failed was you weren't ready
correct you're on the no matter how good
bad or indifferent they were
you needed to get to this point
even by listening for two sentences you
needed to get to this point to actually
now set that person up for success in a
meaningful way
I don't know how to get over like I was
saying to Joe we're we're literally
cutting the cord on the baby that we
birthedral absolutely I'll tell you how
I'll tell you how you do it
the next time you talk as a company an
ad
a video
the website like the next time you do
anything about the company
it it's gonna be a different story
Ricky Thompson in Clifton New Jersey
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you two
foreign
here's the thing I know you touched upon
it like what happened to the ones we did
hire like I jumped in with all my effort
for literally six I would say six seven
months side by side on the phones
letting him listen to me book it was
going well I I maybe just bad luck with
his health and then we're recording and
hearing the messages when when I wasn't
there and I was like let me step away
let me let him do his thing and then
hearing it is just that's the part I
don't know how to get over that cringe
of like I would have said that right
it's an awkward I don't want my well you
didn't you didn't potentially compensate
enough for the right kind of person
correct that's probably what it is it
was a wrong person maybe not the right
uh one you don't understand you're
looking for that unicorn yeah you were
you weren't looking for unicorn you were
looking for a unicorn that was selfishly
filling you
right we're looking for looking for
something that was not only help us you
know somebody that you didn't have to
pay that much or at least not like you
right right somebody that you wanted
somebody that you didn't have to pay
that much that you weren't going to give
Equity to right yeah
no shine away from you you were looking
for a selfish unicorn which is different
than looking for a unicorn
true I am not denying one word that you
are saying listen this is the beauty of
like being around small businesses my
whole life like I really know this [ __ ]
and like I'm so pumped for you guys not
because
I'm pumped because I'm on fire here and
nailing it I'm pumped because you're
ready
you know fast
you can make this work by giving some
kid the 27 year old you five percent of
the company that he or she earns out
over the next three years who's gonna
double the business and you're gonna
have a problem on the other end because
he's going to come to you and be like
your [ __ ] faces I took this business
from five to ten and I only won five
percent what are we gonna do about it
and then the other question is yeah like
when we do pour the gasoline on this
yeah we we like put our own brakes on it
because then it's like you can't handle
it we're getting the guys
that's right the news on that that's
going out in 12 seconds
you're going to have people that work at
Verizon right now making 200 000 a year
driving trucks for you in six months
you have no problem on that that game is
about to come over in about an another
eight weeks
out of the bag
because labor shortage is not going to
be your problem going forward great
because we have multiple we're ready
with the trucks it's an industry problem
thankfully that one is not just our
problem yeah that's an American problem
the government paid printed unlimited
money
right now that money's been deployed
into more dumb [ __ ] right
all right so then I won't use that
excuse that's definitely not excuse we
won't need to get a good one for me yeah
exactly what you that one is to your
point I love how you said that good for
you so here's what I would say
be prepared to give up five percent of
the business
be prepared to give up
no percent of the business in the first
year
hey Carl
we think you're the guy
you get it's a we're going to give you a
you know this is a three-year deal I'm
gonna come in
we're gonna pay you this salary more
than you're accustomed to this is your
investment instead of into a truck into
your [ __ ] happiness
if you crushed like we have to fire you
because on the 366th day according to
this contract you get 2.5 percent of the
company
and on the first day of the next year
you get another 2.5 and then at the end
of the year not only do you get the
salary but in the second year you get
2.5 percent of the profits at the end of
the year
and the same thing in the next year and
you there are a lot of people running
around New Jersey that will do that deal
that are better than you too
that's that's where we're finally
realizing we're so exhausted yes
you you're you're in the best spot ever
you grind it because you loved it yep
now you've decided you love it a little
less
you got the six kids and you want to
[ __ ] now you can travel a little bit
because kobits are like you just want to
live a little bit how do we get over
that whole like perfectionist control
thing when you realize it's a company
not you guys
insights
the saying I'm sorry
to a mistake is more powerful than not
making a mistake
do you know why I'm Never Scared
because when I find that we made a
mistake I call the person I apologize I
make it awesome
you know what can fix your fear
refund people I do it all the time
and that's just it too that that's why
we have a five-star reputation because
we do whatever it takes want to hear
something awesome here's something
awesome if you had four stars on Google
your business would be twice as big
um
that could easily happen
that could easily happen buddy actually
it doesn't have to easily happen if you
give somebody five percent of the
business that is a 28 year old you it
won't happen
gotcha here do you just stirred up
something that I probably we've been
discussing for many years it's um the
oldest gentleman we have
um with our company we started with me
and grinded and he should have been off
the truck five years ago but we
continued continue we increased this pay
so he's doing estimates on the side he's
doing customer customers on the you know
after hours weekends making additional
money so he has a good life a good
living we owe it to him in a sense but
he should be the one that should be a
percentage owner of the company but
right he it he would have to be
retrained it's not something where he's
he does it the way we want we're kind of
stuck with him so I don't know if that's
the right guy but I don't want to just
put it
there's a part of me that says there's a
part of me that says he's not but you
give him one percent
because he's family at this point and he
earned it oh yeah and he's your eyes and
ears and doubles completion system you
nailed that he knows it better than
anybody else right that and that's any
acts like us when nobody's out there I
give him one I give him one percent
I give the new person four or five
and you and that one percent is for
thank you slash
you're going to help this kid succeed my
head is already like you have just the
percentage of the company is something
we have never talked about it's been
commissioned we're always like well we
can give him this much commission right
just a philosophical it's a
philosophical POV
it's your religion that's why you
haven't thought of it Europe
entrepreneurs that are like we don't
give up Equity of the business right
right and 10 years ago we have I got a
Christmas we have a Christmas party we
want to give him something like oh my
God you're staying with us for 10 years
and dedicating your life I mean what
what better Christmas gift it's done
deal
you nailed it it means something to him
he gets an extra bonus every year at the
end of the year on top of everything
else right because that one percent
profit interest is gonna matter
you're right it's huge
James can lead to a bunch of Jersey
business lawyers or stuff like this is a
great strength of his what I just talked
about so I'm sure he'll help awesome
all right we're at time on you guys so
we're gonna go switch over to Rob now
pretty cool what happens when you just
take a different perspective like how it
unlocks every single issue amazing thank
you of course
Rob you're up
oh man that was quick okay uh so I don't
know if you need any more content
okay let's do a squeeze this lemon
what what do you what do you want
specifically oh sorry you said no
contact so so he here's the big thing
that I think I know a ton about you but
what's the current question at hand
gotcha gotcha gotcha so
so we as a family are having a lot of
fun
um so you know right now making probably
around 80 000 a year just making social
media content which is insane
um and so but when we talk to people
that seem to be really in the know uh
like a mutual friend they're saying like
ah it should be way more than that and
so for us it's not about necessarily
making more money
um but we don't want to leave stuff on
the table either so that we could do
some of the fun things that we want to
do
uh so for example like gonna my kids are
designing shirts that they want to sell
now that you know so whether or not we
sell a lot or a little doesn't matter
it's just kind of fun you know down the
road we we want my wife wants to
renovate a house in the small town we
live in uh Like Houses so TLC was
interested but we said no because that's
not the brand for us like we don't want
to be about us but another production
company is pitching to HGTV about the
small town renovation and that kind of
life so so there is some of that we want
to do more media but definitely a
certain brand of it so I guess the big
question is is that of course keep doing
what we're doing I just feel like it
seems as I talk to other people I just
want to make sure that I'm not blind to
what I don't know if there's things that
we can do to level up that we want to be
smart and doing those so you know at 1.7
billion views we haven't put any money
like we haven't paid for any advertising
at all we haven't paid for any like I
think promoting videos yeah how would
you like to make your money
um see that's a tough question I think I
I like to have the option like I think
me personally I just love new things so
like
and so that's really hard to say so like
if we we want to do a coffee shop in a
small town and so I love to make money
that way I love to make money selling
T-shirts I love to make money a brand
like uh you know coming and say hey do a
video for us we pay you ten thousand
that's fun you know it's similar to the
last question why don't you do what the
demilios did they brought in my friend
Greg who worked at UTA as their business
manager
I think you know you know do you want to
be the business
CEO or do you want to still be part of
the content create a process and that's
what you have to decide because
everything you just mentioned are all
viable
I I don't think I'm good enough at
business
we'll help you yeah that that's that's
the question yeah because it's like I
have a sense if I said this is 100 right
which is what I'm telling you yeah the
sense based on how much money you are
making what you'd be willing to pay that
person on salary and then give a
commission of the deals like the what
feels right in your stomach
yeah I mean some of it because right now
I'm just trying to think I'd have to
take a look to see what we could give up
I'd be willing to give up you know as an
investment anything that we could as
long as we can still buy food for the
kids and close
um
salary
well I I mean we would but right now
we're making like 80 000 a year right I
don't know your savings I don't know
your humility of selling stuff like I'm
I'm asking backwards now okay
um
yeah we I mean we just don't have that
much in savings so 70 75k yes
um
don't forget don't forget the concept
there is if you bring in the a killer at
75 and they're out there yeah he or he
generates 330 for you she makes 10 on
the 330 she gets 33 and 75. you're
pumped
yeah yeah of course you're gonna have to
make that bet
okay and so so right now we don't have
an agency that's one of those things so
when you say yes I want you to have a
business
person internal that lives and breathes
the family okay because you won't go
from 80 to 300 without it
okay yeah an agent an agent you're going
to be one of many I want you to be their
only child
okay
uh Joe James
um Julia I'm thinking former Vayner
Talent people something we're talking
about I'm not sure who but 75k stuck to
Hannah let's talk to Dio let's talk to
steal you guys gals can kick around so
let's think about some people remind me
where you live Rob
so it's called Greenville Illinois just
small town of seven thousand forty five
minutes east of St Louis Missouri
okay
yeah
the answer brother
yeah
and and that's and and so that's the
only way as far as like making
additionally now no I'm sorry I mean
that's not the only way the only way is
somebody who's a business person to be
running the business
yeah yeah and and I think we we need
that because I I don't know what I don't
know and I think you know it's fun like
I love to spend time with the family I'm
not always like I like to try things and
just for experience but I'm not the guy
that's going to figure out the bottom
dollar the spell spreadsheets that kind
of stuff it's not my world at all so or
know how to get 38 000 out of you know
almond milk
yeah or know how to do the Creator fund
on Snapchat where you're making 63k from
your impressions yep the business person
that's exactly what we need yes yes
you're stuck because the agent you'll
lose more on
okay you'll waste time and energy people
are always scared to have somebody and
pay them because they're like I'll get
an agent they'll take 20 I have nothing
to lose but you have to lose it they're
not gonna do anything
yeah yeah the mother here lost of your
relevance yeah
yeah so as far as like as far as
platforms go uh Tick Tock Ebbs and flows
it was our biggest you called it a long
time ago in the last year YouTube has
gone crazy for us like in the last year
alone where we grew a half a million
followers 500 million I'm sorry because
all shorts yeah yeah we've done some
long-form content and it just takes a
lot more time and it just doesn't get
the views but our shorts like one short
has like 160 million views how you doing
with Facebook reels
so we couldn't get anywhere with
Facebook reels
um as far as getting the ads turned on
and so we started so so so
um so we actually are going to work well
we jelly smack
um
I don't know if you know the company
they're going they they basically are
running all of that for us now and then
we're splitting Revenue
um
okay
yeah hesitation is on that is just
because you can't monetize the revenue
doesn't mean you should stay take the
attention
too expensive I think James but he
should meet him
Alex see someone's a great name he's he
won't take 75 but he might
he might take I like him a lot James so
and I like the tall family a lot so
there's maybe a scenario where
they pay him a certain amount and I'll
kick in some money of like guaranteed
revenue from marketing like yeah that's
a good name definitely reach out to him
yeah and I get that with on Facebook and
so that was we kind of felt stuck and
and again not not no we're just trying
to figure out ways to get going and so
like yeah with the Jelly sacks minute
scenario felt like we weren't do we we
just weren't doing anything there anyway
and it felt like trying to get some
traction and and so uh that that may
have been the wrong move to go but
I'm just uh that's not a big deal yeah
it's like that's like a splinter in a
world of cancer your cancers you don't
have a business person yeah okay yeah
yeah that makes sense
we'll get on it okay there's really
nothing else I mean we'll we'll keep
going because there's really nothing
else to say here yeah I know too much
about how much good quality creative you
have you you should be doing everything
with anything that touches
big and tall tall culture like there's a
ton of business yeah so do you think
coming into in you know three years ago
I I well I mean we only started this 20
months ago but I did take your advice
and went on LinkedIn and and messaged
every company I could think of that
um and even you know any product that we
we use at all
nothing I'm just the last thing is like
we've never let that never led to one
deal yeah because you're not good enough
at it yeah
which is okay
I got F's in school
you know it's what I didn't know at the
time nor did you really was were you a
natural salesman
it's okay that you're not
yeah who gives a [ __ ] yeah I think you
need one
yeah
all right so so next step should I reach
out to Alex
I just uh DM them right now
and Julia are gonna gather strategize
yeah we've got this whole thing recorded
we're taking notes we'll be doing the
reach out and we'll reach back out to
you rob we'll take the next step for you
okay love it so totally it's curveball
because I maybe have one more minute
here left
um so how do you feel about lava
resilient Red Devil still
I feel like I'm going to build the next
Sesame Street meets Pokemon and that
everybody that has a boyfriend will be
happy with me that I did
and obviously the Red Devil is super hot
in our world so it's better to have
Pikachu than it is to have shmikachu
yeah no I'll say like and I took your
advice I sold everything we made money
on nfts and so the hollow wizard won
Hollow wizard 2 and the Red Devil it's
it they're just sitting there until my
kids kill me off Monster
yeah it's a fun one here is one hollow
wizard
it's a monster
yeah it's funny if I'm right even
halfway right it's a monster
no all right so all right yeah thank you
so much Gary thank you enjoy go ahead
um so I know since you have to go mine
really is about
uh traditionally electoral contact
company so really like service and make
the money and go so we kind of stumbled
in over covet making this support media
content as a result of our kids and all
our kids friends and so what I know like
my family's a good sports family so four
percent of the kids make it pro no
matter what Athletics what they play so
they invest all this time right
um and I know that 50 of the fun office
staff in Pro Sports make over 100k but
there's very really little information
about the pipeline for kids to get there
they have to go to college usually to
even make it in Pro Sports other than
basketball so you're dumping money into
that with the hopes of getting picked up
and then you don't so they end up with
debt and bum jobs and really no segue
into a life in sports after they play
sports four eight nine ten years
um
you know go ahead keep going
yeah so and starting this small Sports
content thing on Tick Tock and YouTube
again just fell into it I started
looking at okay how can that Gap be
Bridge could we do a media company that
had like creator games and the kids
actually get hands-on experience and
being coaches and VP in person almost
like I guess ESPN and exchange this is
in Reverse but
um and because I come from such a very
traditional service where I'm like okay
how do you make a business that sells
and makes money I know Vayner random
Community engagement
is that the same as like a bajillion
eyeballs and then itself because that
seems very nice you've got a big
Advantage it's going to all these
Fortune 500 Brands and saying hey
remember 24 months ago when you guys all
committed to giving so much money to
Black owned businesses and you haven't
done any of it yet
well hello I'm here and look at this
space and hey Under Armor hey Procter
and Gamble hey Pepsi hey [ __ ] that
you all talk that big [ __ ] game
write me a five hundred thousand dollar
check to be the sponsor of my [ __ ]
thing
Joy you will not believe how many people
will do it there I live in this world
they're very concerned that they haven't
wrote the checks that their mouth said
they were going to do and that the Wall
Street Journal or at age are going to
call them out
so should we do the play of having kids
make myself
I apologize to it Joe what she needs to
do is create a vcon
right create remember the volleyball
lady from the last meeting yeah Tara she
needs to create her Super Bowl of this
of these right her game her weekend her
thing
she needs to figure out what the cost of
that is it's going to cost me 219 to put
this on
and we need to she needs to make a deck
and we need to help because we love
to make that deck sellable
to somebody for 400 000.
there you go
now she's got all that money
she spends some of that profit on
filming everything making unlimited
content
and basically you're in the media events
business Joy
yes
here you use the meat the content to now
put you in a position for me to give you
the business track of you should do an
event
you got to make a badass deck but you
have a big Advantage my dear
which is not as been a historical
advantage in this country
these companies are in a bad [ __ ]
place they've made big commitments and
they have not delivered and with my
co-sign we'll get you meetings
I'm there so is it the way you think
about the content in the event is it
really
in terms of Super Bowl or is it all the
games as well leading up to the big
Super Bowl how do you think about it I
think you need to do an event
like right like I don't think you I
don't think you got it like that yet I
think you could pull off a weekend but I
don't think you're ready to have like a
league
yeah okay
we start small let's do the you know
youth con you know or youth bowl or
whatever you call it I don't have all
the details obviously we're just
starting but basically this weekend
where do you live
Virginia love it literally
you know try to think of Brands um
North Carolina
obviously Atlanta but those are more
expensive I like Virginia I think you
could do it there
I I like I like Char I like Charlotte a
lot because the suburbs of Charlotte you
can get the proper field Brands like it
there there's Brands there
and you put on a [ __ ] Olympics or
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing you know
like an event
to put their logo on all the [ __ ]
gear and you'll give them content after
the fact once you got the big one
you go now you get the 25k for Piggly
wigglies and 25k from Bojangles I'm on
the board of Bojangles I'll make sure I
help you
okay all right now you're on your
[ __ ] way you have a business model
Sports perspective are you more towards
basketball because Maryland and Virginia
as a combo tons of talent in that region
like it might be a great place just
because based on the high schools alone
yeah we're like football basketball
years ago and everybody was like I'm
like you don't sleep onto the ball so
I'm not married I mean we are big
football and I think DMV in general is
like we want a football thing because we
don't really have one
um but I'm open to whatever it needs to
be we have kids who are doing like
lacrosse and all of them end up in the
same bag
um and so I'm open to whatever it needs
to be for it to win
we'll give you some help for sure as
Gary mentioned we'll we'll help you
build the deck and we'll get you guys
running
um for sure that's awesome thank you
foreign
that you want to impart upon Joy or any
of the other guests yeah Joy needs to
make it clear to people what they're
getting we're gonna have these in the
morning on Saturday eight teams put
together by my crew compete then it's
four then it's the final four at night
then the championship games in the
morning then we have a keynote speech
about building these kids up in life
here are these four speakers
you know we got to make a real events
deck Joe and I feel like you can find
the Robert Souza James you have your
hands and all the alumni of our history
here the shoes of this and the Kim
Garcia that and a million other things I
know you know James so just help her
make that proper deck then I'll come in
and help her get the meetings for
sponsorship and then she has a business
model then she's going to taste blood in
the water she's like oh [ __ ] okay
if I get more eyeballs on my content
then I can charge more next year and
she's got something
yeah
very cool will do
Rob that's what a business person can do
like if I'm your business person I'm
like why don't we create tall con at the
Javits Center everybody on Earth who's
six seven and over come
oh Gary you're over six seven
six eight
six foot eight I qualified
that's right where she comes from we
might be a big fee we might be both Gary
but we were a foot apart
these stories about left-handers you go
buy golf clubs and baseball well you
know what you know what I mean Rob all
of a sudden you can imagine how
if you're making a piece of a piece of
content every day of like tall con
you know Chicago Hilton 2023 every
single person that it's in your bio
every person that sees a viral video you
know what they're gonna do Gary's one of
those six mixed kids is gonna see it
they're gonna send it to Big Gary over
there and be like you should go you know
like humans one of the biggest issues in
society is tribalism
the reason we have race and gender
religious issues is people like to team
up
with their own
you know a tall conference would be
[ __ ] cool
jokes about being pissed at company by
the way you can start really making
change when you do something like that
yeah can you guess speak at a tall
conference or no
I think I'd be eliminated brother but
you know you know what's cool about that
five years in you could like change the
laws of like how much airplane space
there like you could do [ __ ] right I
keep thinking about the things that
culture hasn't gotten to like so I've
been obsessed with this concept of
beauty privilege
you know people talk about like white
male privilege they talk about wealth
privilege there's no bigger privilege in
our society than Beauty
right I'm like when are they going to
get the pretty people then I think about
like who are we going to support like
being tall like real tall
like there's a lot of challenges with
showers and flights and like real [ __ ] I
got I got some bumps
so
some fun stuff like that I just think
about where the winds are going to blow
yeah and for us it's and we don't want
to try to be like altruistic because
that's not I mean we we are but what
we've found is that everyone thinks that
tall people like have it made and so the
amount like my girls who are tall and
skinny and I've been I was skinny until
I was like 30 years old there's nothing
they could do but the amount of time
she's told to eat a cheeseburger and
stuff and and how basketball coaches
expect more out of the tall kids and and
so it's not about that but that's one of
the yeah if we're gonna worry about
people's self-esteem we should worry
about every variation we're aware of
what a poor kid's self-esteem issue is
we're aware of what a dyslexic kid's
self-esteem is we're aware of a black or
brown skinned in America self-esteem a
Jew in Europe self-esteem we know about
these things I don't think we talk about
someone who's six seven at eleven what
their problems are
and by the way I'll go the reverse when
your entire life's value system is
predicated on how attractive you are you
should see what happens these people
have 40.
there's no greater decline to depression
than somebody who's ripping attractive
up to 40 and then they start losing
their self-worth and start doing all
sorts of plastic surgery all sorts of
[ __ ] if you've been told your whole life
you're a [ __ ] you're something
because of this you can [ __ ] change a
lot of things to fit you know father
times undefeated
so I like these conversations you know
it makes us more compassionate and
thoughtful I'm very I look at every
person on Earth every moment I move and
say I think about my children
incredibly wealthy right I'm like I
would die if I was Xander die
knowing that everything I accomplished
in life forever people would say to me
yeah but garyvee your dad did it yeah
that sucks if you're capable it's one
thing if you're a schlemelon you're like
[ __ ] it at least I got a nice life but
if you've got it like that
so everyone's got something and until we
realize that
there's nobody when I generalize and
stereotype by far the people that I
think are most upset are rich white
dudes
you never hear that but I've been around
the world and I can tell you
it's an it's a really tough group
it's a lot of bad behavior holding up
those facades
[Music]
and Security's real so anyway love you
gang thank you
[Music]